howdy howdy howdy welcome back to M
cubed and Sidetrack we're jamming out
today we we've got some fun stuff to
talk about not a whole whole lot there
is a decent little bit of news this week
for film and stuff which is nice because
it's kind of been a little bit lacking
with all the strikes going on and stuff
but there is some striking news not
necessarily striking news but Marvel VFX
teams have joined iatc in a unionized
vote and
they are now unionized so that's that's
kind of cool and relevant within the
stripes and stuff Disney and Spectrum
have reached a deal after a 10-day
impasse and that 10-day impasse could
have done
a couple different things in a couple
different ways and it was very
interesting the way it turned out
because cable might be back in a way
that we didn't think it was it was it
was so interesting that I saw this story
I couldn't be asked to read it so you'll
have to explain it to me we've got this
but you know what the most exciting
thing is that we're talking about today
aliens
aliens you know uh I I wish I could say
it as good as what's his name from The
History Channel but
daily
it it it's it's aliens
you know it's not aliens
but it's aliens
they look suspiciously asgard-like which
made me happy they did right all right
so now we roll This intro
do it
[Music]
I'd say we just jump in right on Aliens
where where where do we even start howdy
everybody howdy Sidetrack I mean
Sidetrack we're sidetracked sci-fi quest
uh I was reading Sidetrack grinder howdy
bread howdy David howdy everybody
um
that's not we're starting the
interesting topic the aliens
what the actual
so these two little alien dudes
have been presented
mummified and presented yeah well ain't
non-human alien corpses which is an
oxymoron but we'll let that go because
I'll just read this on the independent
um it's displayed at the Mexican
Congress basically so not just like in a
shoe cupboard somewhere in Congress
in one of the largest nations on this
planet yeah and they think there's a
thousand years old but on the um I I
just love on the story that I'm reading
it says has stirred excitement in the
alien conspiracy
um Community alien conspiracy community
that just makes it sound like Nutters
but you know anyway
it looks so much like an Asgard it's
just that's the first thing I thought I
I think I put Instagram stories with a
little Asgard behind it it was crazy
to me that's wrong it does and I'd have
made in clay when I was at
um in school and not very good at making
things out of clay
do do you think that is oh I didn't see
that's interesting
um I mean obviously it's mummified which
makes it look more clay-like but it has
that large small small body large head
that we were kind of used to in Aliens
obviously us us Gators we We Like Us in
Asgard uh but we you've seen this before
right the skeleton that we were like
it's in some Museum somewhere
um so that that basically is a two-hour
documentary and their conclusion was we
don't know what it is
um so I'm in two minds about that but
you know I'm not
um Dr Stephen Green's biggest fan
um I think he did an amazing work early
on in his career do getting getting all
those people together
um and doing the
um the the the news core thing that he
did and but then he has gone on to just
try to make money out of UFO I think he
makes big claims that he has no
intention of backing up and yeah it's
just a con basically is he the guy that
found the skeleton a long time ago
um no he didn't actually find that
skeleton he just
um let me just turn my green screen off
to my green screens just in the corner
and that's not to mess in my uh
um
but um
he was just he he it was presented to
him and he basically paid for a lot of
research we've done and they they looked
into it and the conclusion was they
didn't know what it was they think it's
a pygmy basically it's it's a deformed
you mean baby
um but they don't really know what it
was the interesting thing about these
things I've been found today was though
that if it's if human's not a hoax yes
um there has been work done so there's a
Mr Musa
Mouse on
mousean
Mr M
um he was one of the there was a public
hearing today when these things were
presented and they actually said that
they had they had removed DNA
um from the
Asgard yeah and they had radiocarbonated
it they believe from radiocarbon dating
the objects are at least a thousand
years old and that when they did DNA
samples it was found that over 30 of the
specimens specimens DNA was classed as
unknown
X range of the specimens are also shown
during the hearing which experts testify
under oath that one of the bodies is
seen to have eggs inside it oh oh that's
what that okay I see
um and while said to have implants made
under of made of rare Metals such as
ozmune
um
Ryan Graves Americans for safe areas
based executive director and former U.S
Navy was in attendance having earlier
um said the U.S Congress of the threat
of money then foreign phenomenon posed
by U.S national security
um oh Mr here's the interesting bit at
the end Mr Mayo Sam
has previously been associated with
claims with alien discoveries that have
later been debunked including five
mummies found in Peru in 2017 that were
later shown to be
human children
um
this
I could see that this could be a pig or
a small child I guess but the school
just
the school howdy everyone damn it Harris
I love everyone saying howdy it makes me
happy be happy uh
hello we want to believe like we want it
to be in Asgard an E.T we wanted to be
something you know
it's an alien drug mule that's what it
is it's just it kind of seems like it I
don't know if it's a thousand years ago
could it be an extinct
off Branch like small little population
of pygmy humans that were living
somewhere and they were found or
something well as you know the things as
you know that I don't believe in
evolution
um because
um I generally think that if we all came
from monkeys how come they're still
monkeys
so you know hello two and two um
you don't know if I'm joking about this
are you trying to figure out
um I am trying to figure out
sorry it was a meme that was um shared
with my on my post a couple of days ago
because some of them are going uh
Evolution if it if we all come from
monkeys then why they're still monkeys
hello and like she's been really clever
and it was like that you're wrong from
the beginning because we didn't come
from monkeys with it but anyway
um so it could be some thing that was
evolutionary
that's evolved and disappeared now of
course it could be and if something's
monetized or mummified naturally as well
it does distort the skin shrinks all the
fluids removed so it could have looked
very different when it was you know
alive
so maybe
do do we know how they've okay they
found it in the the mining shaft right
or aim old mining Shaft or something
along those lines so it was mummified
naturally and not necessarily
by by a group of people
all right so there could be some things
in there that
are are iffy make it a little less valid
um unfortunately as you guys know I used
to have a conspiracy and a mystery
Channel got um called
um uh mystery machine
um and we spent three years going
through all the different Mysteries UFOs
all these sorts of things I was actually
talked about my talking about this one
mate that I did those channels with
and that videos with last night and he
was still saying look look you don't
believe aliens are visiting the Earth
because that's that's that's why one of
the main reasons I stopped doing the
channel I stopped believing in them
because every time I dug into anything I
always found that there was almost
always not always but almost always
there was a very logical explanation
behind the mystery or the Witnesses were
very dodgy or
um things like this everything I did it
just and I started to get really
depressed with it I'm just like this is
I'm wasting my time there's nothing here
I'm not going to argue that aliens don't
exist and intelligent life doesn't exist
yeah I'm not convinced of visiting the
Earth
and that that is such a depressing thing
for me because I've always been
convinced they were
you know um and I actually generally
think that if they could get here they
would because I actually think
intelligent life is probably very rare
in the universe so if an alien species
discovered us they would come here to to
like research us and you know learn
about us
um yeah I'm just not convinced they are
you convinced they ever have
that that would be different because
there are some
um
some evidence to suggest possibly
um there's there is DNA evidence is very
suspicious there's there's doing things
like this
um but
if they did I think they would continue
and I'd like to say I actually think
Nico Pope is another one who's a big UFO
um conspiracyness and if you actually
look into his history he's a [__]
artist excuse my friend
um the man is straight up a liar
so I'm going to backtrack that slightly
because I don't want to get sued but
also it's not quite true he's a he's an
exaggerator he's hyperable yeah he
dangle strings and lets other people say
oh my God that makes you the real life
Mulder and then he just doesn't like
argue with them
um so that I think that's fair but he
actually said something that's really
sensible he says that 95 of stuff that
we see isn't true is is is explainable I
should say isn't UFOs it's the five
percent of stuff we struggle to explain
that's interesting and that is true but
if you research these things even like
some of the famous ones like Roswell
there are like explanations behind it
that make more sense than a UFO crashing
you know what I mean
um there are very few UFO sightings that
don't
um that aren't
explainable in some way yeah yeah even
the famous Pentagon videos of the Tic
Tac the Speedster and the gimbal there
are people out there that say they're
very mundane very boring explanations
for this and their arguments are quite
convincing cord or accrue their VFX
house that I bring up every now and then
one of the they're like off and on kind
of series that they always do one of
their Sunday video series I guess is
debunking UFO or debunking like
Sasquatch videos or debunking this and
it's their VFX house they can kind of
figure out what's practical what's not
did someone put a little effect in here
did they not did they just tweak a
little camera movement or what did they
do and uh it's it's interesting to see
it was a balloon
or yesterday right yeah I think it was
because it hit our thing today and
obviously you guys are like eight hours
behind us so it was only the first thing
this morning or it was um yesterday
um but yeah it was within the last 24 48
hours
if it's not true
or if it is another hoax because again
remember we've had loads of these
focuses over the years and it's it
always says then the the
um
uh Mexican government are going to be
really pissed off
stupid
so on the thought process of that uh
there was a great comment earlier
[Music]
um
oh wait was it why show it now maybe all
that hype made them see they were
missing a Payday I possibly I just love
the fact that the Mexican Government was
like you know what all this the US
government all these other different
people they keep releasing all this UFO
stuff holding my beer or excuse me hold
my cerveza here here's aliens mummified
in the middle of like our uh one of
their judicial courts you know one of
their like most official places to to
hold anything yeah
I've actually realized what he's talking
about
Roswell was probably a balloon and that
that is is the most ridiculous thing to
actually say because it's an ongoing
joke isn't it sibling but it was
actually a very top secret
um I want to say that the um project was
called something like mardok but I'm
saying off top of my head Martock or
something like that
um and it was to
um a very very high altitude balloon
that could sense for nuclear weapons
going off because they were going to to
see what the Russians were up to it was
highly highly um experimental and highly
Secret
um and it crashed so the Americans went
nuts closed everything down lied about
it for like 50 years and then very
recently said no actually it was this
balloon thing
um but the problem is obviously because
they lied so much now we don't believe
them and I I can't help but think oh
they're the you know they're the boys
that cried wolf and then they're going I
think it was the test balloon
and then people have been trying to get
a Payday off it ever since
um
because I mean there's there's a lot of
people out there that do just one
a little extra something in their
pockets and a little extra something to
line their pockets but
there are also some of these guys that
if they didn't believe in what they're
doing
I don't think they'd be doing it there
are some that definitely would be doing
something like it no matter what they're
just con people at heart and that's just
kind of like but those they're they're
not easy to differentiate all the time
necessarily but they are
differentiatable
so that so want this to be true they
just make up stories and they just make
it up there are people like Robert
Cooper that just to be honest
lie and I think he did it for the
notoriety and he was a con artist he was
he was I mean if you actually look into
the warts in all of his history it's
colorful to say the least and but he
says he saw UFOs because he was an
astronaut people believed him astronaut
sees UFO and sees aliens yeah he was
also caught in a few little contracts
later with him car dealerships and
things that got him into a lot of
trouble
um
I actually believe
I actually I think I believe a lot of
what Bob says I actually think it might
be true
but there's so much stuff there that you
like go
you're making it hard for us Bob he's
making it hard but also he's one of
those few that like I think he would fit
in the category of loves it so much it's
so into it that I don't know if he's
convinced himself it's real but one way
or another he believes like it is real
um
the mind's a powerful thing could
someone convince themselves that these
things are real as well um
credibility really came from the fact he
was one of the first ones to talk about
area 51. but what they don't tell you
was it was well known in Vegas area
about this base and that that one
aircraft used to fly out the James
Airways used to fly out to this base
with these people I thought it was known
it was just nobody ever like talked to a
news reporter about it
um but it wasn't it wasn't there and the
incident didn't exist
he was just the first one to capture so
yeah it's it's difficult
it's really a theme and if you actually
look at these things with an open mind
without cognitive or you try to ignore
your cognitive biasing that that's
actually impossible and it was a look
goodbye so I open mind like that it's
not physically possible but you do you
just do your best to to you know
um understand these things if you do
that you have to consider both sides of
the argument and you have to look past
just the
um interesting story that someone's
telling you have to try and look into
the thing behind it
and then a lot of the time it's
depressing and I got called so much [__]
for this but at the same time all those
people that are like very gung-ho on
debunking they're they're very much in
like the exact 180 Camp of the people
that are trying to prove it's real
mm-hmm so they could be leaning into
their biasing just as much
Umar is in the middle but I remember
talking about 9 11 and um and and this
is a few years ago now but I actually
genuinely think there are and some of
the conspiracies that go around I love
this is ridiculous they're just stupid
um and I tried to talk about it really
respectfully but what I ended up doing
was annoying both sides of the argument
the conspiracy nuts who think it was a
control Demolition and all this sort of
thing went absolutely good for me and
like I say I had death rats oh god well
the people just believe it was complete
accents and there's no conspiracy and
I'm like there's quite a lot of evidence
just at least some of this I think the
American government has at least known
about it and maybe even maybe let it
happen
um the Pentagon bit is very dodgy
um that you know um but they went they
went for me as well so it's like both
sides of people because I'm gonna go at
me
um
and you know she's like you've got to
try to look at these things what the
where the everything like you know let
the evidence take you somewhere rather
than trying to find the evidence that
suits what you believe and that's yeah
whether you're able to completely look
at it objectively or not
look for the most General rationale and
not necessarily like the biased
rationale I guess or at least a tip two
that's always easier said than done uh
um
Society come after me as well
I was really mean to them in the video
I could have strongly worded email up
you were like sorry you're wrong have a
good one idiot
um I wasn't very nice about him but yeah
the Earth is the Earth is a globe I'm
afraid oh no oh no this one this cracked
me up specifically because while I was
giving blood yesterday which is why this
wasn't a movie Tuesday stream yesterday
I was supposed to look be two and a half
hours I was there for almost six it was
a lot
um but yeah
I watched District 9 while I was giving
blood which I love District nine and
that just that comment made me
immediately think of District nine I
can't wait for district 10 when they
eventually do that hopefully it's
actually definitely happening now it has
confirmed it and like it's been in
development hell for however long I've
read something about it not long ago
um I'll I'll see if I can find out
what's going on with it the problem is
that these strikes everything's
it's all South African uh even if you
get strawto Copley back the guy that
played it he played in Beast alongside
elbow it's all South African films yeah
they could in theory get get going
anyway well I
the strikes I think we've broke the
we've got three or four months left of
these strikes potentially but that's
not too bad if they're if they think
about development work now there's stuff
they can get done in there in that time
yeah particularly if they've already got
script they're happy with there's plenty
to get done in three or four months and
and thankfully a lot of the like a24s
and Neons and
smaller big bigger smaller Studios is
the better way to say that I guess are
capable of
getting a lot of projects out that they
were planning to do anyway and they're
kind of given the golden platter at the
moment which is it's beautiful to see
it's beautiful to see
um so what do you think genuine
potential Maybe
I I
attempt to stay objective I want them
doll I want every single thing anybody
says to be real I just I wanted I want
them to be here
but I don't I I we haven't been shown
anything just proof wise like strong
enough that's just completely convinced
me of such I guess so I'm open to all
suggestions conspiracies thoughts
etc etc etc I I just I I won't Subs
subscribe to something I guess until I
wouldn't waste any serious time on it no
and that's kind of where I'm at that's
yeah
just like
someone someone plan out the evidence
and like get the debunk then let me
watch both then I'll kind of make a
decision
yeah it's interesting in the meantime
yeah that's that's more like where I'm
at uh I'm with you it's very interesting
but hmm
well
you know I don't know that but you know
Stargate does touch on that a little bit
because the the Asgard we're humans that
clone themselves or human-like very
similar to humans at least they clone
themselves into being Little Green Men
maybe they were the Ancients at a
certain point they looked More Humans at
one point yeah I've since I'm watching
Star get Atlantis at the moment and the
Pegasus Asgard just turned up
very happy boy I hope there is I I love
the idea of a Ronin movie going into
Pegasus and actually I
think that'd be the best way to not the
best way necessarily but I like that
Avenue of
I think we'll talk about it at the
weekend because there's been a lot of
people saying they're not a big fan of
that idea
really and I just think about from a
maybe a slightly boring if I was the
producer if it was my money
and Jason Momoa was interested I would
scrap everything we've done to that
point and I would make a Jason Momoa
Stargate movie as a two-hour advert and
then kick off into whatever else because
you're pretty guaranteed you're you're
very least gonna make your money back
that would that would just be my only
reasoning for it Stargate fans might
have gone really
but
everybody at the studio will be going
yes
that's all I don't care about
um even for Stargate fans it might not
be like that thing where we want SGU to
be kind of finished we want sg1 to pick
up somewhere again SGA is kind of
um even though it may be a good portion
of the fan base's favorite it's kind of
that one in limbo because sg1 would be
like the natural team to bring back SGU
would be like the the conclusion that
needs that's necessary I guess uh it'd
be nice to kind of have SGA bridge that
Gap in a certain way I would like to
like say he is
some whatever reason left the SGC it
goes out he's trying to fight The Wraith
he finds out that there's a threat
against Earth he comes back half two
thirds away through the film he turns up
at the SGC and then we see some of the
familiar characters and then those
familiar characters then have to battle
it it's still a Jason Momoa movie he's
the main star for two-thirds of it he's
going to be all over the posters
Executives will all have massive
erections hoping that they're going to
make a lot of money
um if they're men they might men might
be women either way
um and yeah and and then but then the
gates could be happy as well that's a
big a lot of people saying they say it
won't be Stargate it won't be Stargate
because it's just a Jason Momoa film and
I'm like yeah but it's an
we want the film to be successful that's
the main thing the film has to be
successful if it's not it's going to
kill the franchise so we're not going to
get a Stargate movie
but even even if it is a ronin decks
Jason Moore film they would have to play
into what was if he's back in the
Pegasus Galaxy
because he didn't he flew with him to
earth right
okay so if he's back in the Pegasus
Galaxy Maybe Taylor went back with him
to be with us
as far as we know yeah
so I guess they would have had to
transport him back at a certain point or
yeah but we've got zpm so we could go
back just to another game or just use
the uh different gates in the sky
um The Gate Bridge was knackered but
um uh because the
um race
they got smashed up so that the The Gate
Bridge was knackered but they had a zpm
so they they basically just zpm once a
week so they only have to have another
address as far as I know they could date
back to the Pegasus
um they can't use the hyperdrive engine
uh they say the um
broken
and they didn't and Sam told us she
didn't know how to fix it so I don't
want any more comments on the damn
Channel about the wormholes
broken
leave it alone they might have fixed it
by now it's been 10 years
I said we've got ships that could fly
there as well so you know we've there's
no reason to say that the deadliest or
whatever else the you know the Hammond
wouldn't be going back to the Pegasus
Galaxy for Stuff
that's yeah that's definitely true I I
just I feel like that would be a good
way to bridge the gap if we have an
excuse to reason all these possibilities
capabilities of putting Ronin back where
he's from which is probably where he'd
like to be even though his found family
might be on earth I would think a lot of
them even if they were stationed on
Earth after Atlantis went back and
Atlantis didn't necessarily if Atlanta
stayed on planet I think some of them
would go back to Pegasus maybe not all
but I think Shepard would Shepard would
probably go back to Pegasus with Ronan
honestly
um that's
that's just I I I'm trying to
rationalize for the characters for the
movie itself I don't think that would
probably happen if that was the case
it could be cool to see Ronan and Taylor
still kicking out there though Taylor
her people have thrived maybe
um maybe Ronan has had to team up with
the Jedi to outrun and try to find a
good way to fight The Wraith while the
Asgard of Pegasus whatever I'm trying to
say they would be great for him to team
up with they're a little more aggressive
a little more militaristic so that would
have been I'd like to see him on his own
though for a big chunk of the film
because I want to see it drip back to
something simple if it was me I'd want
to see
him in the woods with his gun for a good
chunk of the film
yes running basically just really simple
trap predatory you know traps fighting
from The Wraith fighting for his life
and then then over the other thing
getting big more people come in and the
film gets bigger it's towards the end of
the thing but I quite like it be
simplified and
you know a little bit gritty at the
start and see and see where we go from
there
um
we're not in charge unfortunately that
range is fan fictioning now yeah
um
I've heard a little bit about um this is
like this is
Source but he's like talked to a friend
who's talked to a friend who's talked to
a friend so it's one of those sort of
rumors
um but apparently the director who
hasn't officially signed on
virtually scrapped everything that
they've come up to it so far and wants
to change everything
so um is that who I'm thinking it is
possibly
that's who we think it is
oh but um because I think it's unfair
because it just in case but we think it
might be him
um and he wants to do
everything different so apparently it's
caused loads because you know there's
been loads of infighting between MGM
we'll talk about this at the weekend as
well there's been lots of information
between MGM and
um Amazon basically see any Stivers
talked about this loads how it can't
seem to make their bloody Minds up and
this is why we keep going you know the
different rumors we've had over two
years it's just been like okay well now
we think we're doing this yeah now
apparently we're not apparently they're
doing something else and it's gone on
and on and off
um because you know there's just all
these different ideas bouncing around
um
apparently the movie is still on it's
still going to be the Cinematic movie
because that's the only thing that
apparently
um Jenny uh Jennifer lulkey is like
she's just a place to go I want a movie
okay any other ideas no no just do it
and she's basically just gone there you
go just get it done she doesn't it's it
seems she doesn't care what the actual
result is she just wants a movie so um
that's a great management so um
but I think it's
the director on this I think this so
there's been loads of development work
and stuff and obviously we think penguin
and park has been involved a lot and a
lot has just been done we think there's
a script
but they've brought the director in
because that's like the last step now
and the directors may be gone
this isn't right we've got to change
this this and this and I'm just like but
the one person I was speaking to said he
was speaking to somebody who's being
somebody's big somebody I personally
they're they're really really pissed off
over at MGM because they said we didn't
have any direction anyway and now we've
got none we don't know what's going on
there
um you hire a director for direction and
there's and if you if it's a director
for hire if the director didn't develop
it themselves then they are a director
for hire you can't come in there and
change everything
the dotted line while the scripts are on
that's the one thing he will not sign up
to it out of like respect what's going
on so he says as soon as this things are
done so apparently there's loads of
stuff going on but it's all like
unofficial
and um I did speak to another person
I've sort of explained this to them a
friend of the channel and they sort of
said that's common that's normal
there's it's there's just the director
comes in and then hopefully you start
getting a lot of things because until
then there's just loads and loads of
Executives going this is a good idea
this is a good idea
yeah does he expects everything to get
focused there but it's still not at all
after that's that's the hard part and
what the nuisance is because of that
we've got these
these sources normally we wouldn't know
anything about this that's true but we
know every little thing that's going on
and it's just I don't know we know bits
I always keep trying to tell people we
only know we only see slithers of what's
going on there's loads more going on I
think but we see slithers of it and it's
confusing as hell and it's um but
William Arnold
Aaron sorry thank you so much for the
contribution so that really helped the
channel
um I don't know who it goes to because
they're on both channels I won't
monetize you or not I get it thank you
and now I think it would be in Stargate
Atlantis but then all you do is you
bring into a Flanagan
foreign
[Music]
yes
no I I got a phone call let me real
quick do you mind if I hop out just
answer this just to see what it is yeah
I'll just sit here and talk on my own if
you have 20 seconds I'll be back
actually never mind it just it just hung
up so we're good
One Professional Harris I don't know
what you're doing well
it could be an important one I don't
think so though we'll be good we'll be
good uh no I
we know it's coming from I hope it's
Stargate Atlantis not uh Aquaman
Atlantis of course uh what would you
just ask
there would be some confusion like
excuse me I've not thought of that there
will be people that think this is an
Aquaman movie because some people think
um you couldn't actually hurt it more
than it could help you just don't call
this target Atlantis
yeah you just call it Stargate I call it
Stargate revenged in the um in my thing
so you just don't mention Atlantis I
think that's an easy way around it just
don't mention before instead of saying
Logan's Run it could be Stargate ronan's
run
foreign
she gets naked at some point I'm on
board
Rohan just
romantis
that sounds almost Lord of the Rings
like honestly
soundtrack the movie starring Ronan Dex
and me
she got this cameo in his Eris box Jr in
the background somewhere I'm I'm
fighting for this semi-imaginary
character
seven of me fighting Ronin I'll be a
Wraith
already
done
see now you need fake teeth long white
wig and lots of Prosthetics
perfect
on it what was what was the other topic
we went on so
um I think the
issue or what are the the union stuff at
the end that's easy to just crawl back
into
um
because I don't know and I don't really
care so go for it well you might you
might care just because you got a family
to to pay for for film and stuff how
many streaming services do you pay for
at the moment all of them
do you pay for cable
that we don't really have cable I have
satellite so I have Sky TV which that's
where I basically get my HBO from
because we don't have HBO Max here so we
have Sky Atlantic which has all the HBO
stuff I have
Disney Paramount Amazon
and Netflix
yeah I'm watching Paramount mostly oh
and I've got um Apple obviously yeah
sorry I've got like six
okay so if you were a subscriber to
Spectrum or if you're a subscriber on
satellite all right
there is a computer company or something
I really didn't read the story Spectrum
over here is a computer company
it may have been it's essentially Time
Warner Cable spectrum is what Time
Warner Cable was if that's an easy way
to think of that so
so what Disney has done because they had
an impasse not with just Spectrum but
YouTube TV and a couple other cable
television providers and they figured
those out pretty quickly and they were
kind of like their normal Deals they
were just kind of like figuring out
prices like Disney doesn't want to pay
so much they're kind of trying to save
some cash right now but we still want to
cable is a big enough area where it's a
necessity for them to still invest in so
they had a 10-day impasse which is kind
of a longer impact than usual with
Spectrum a Time Warner Cable for
putting Disney content ABC ESPN Disney
plus stuff etc etc all on cable and you
know ESPN and ABC particularly and the
Disney Channel and Disney XD all these
little sub channels they have are all
Disney Channels like they're all
channels meant for cable so if you
subscribe to Cable you get all of those
as usual now that they have pass their
impasse
but
the weird thing is
Disney has now made a deal if you are a
cable subscriber to Spectrum you now get
Disney plus and ESPN plus all the ABC
stuff I'm not sure if you get Hulu or
not but you at least get ESPN plus and
Disney plus with your cable subscription
okay is this more likely Wi-Fi though
something
say what so we I've got a similar thing
that my sky TV I get Netflix free
with my sky TV so is it that type of
thing yeah I actually walked in I have
to watch it through my Skybox but it
comes through the Wi-Fi it comes through
the internet yes so
it'd be the same thing essentially with
these two big of companies doing that
and if they're already doing that across
the pond that it'd be kind of a simple
thing to keep an effect or maybe
in North America and all these other
different places Maybe
put put these streaming services that
are proving to not be as
profitable as they probably wanted them
to be all these different companies
will it be more profitable just go back
into the old cable kind of service and
have them
just just be offered as subsidiary
channels to your cable package
do you think we're seeing a return to
Cable in the way that we thought
streaming was just gonna destroy
everything
I I think it's possible because I think
so I was thinking recently that I might
get rid of the sky TV because I say we
pay for it it's quite expensive
um but we get a deal that we get our
Broadband as part of it so it's actually
with the broadband and the Netflix
included it's actually quite a good deal
I think it's only about 40 pounds a
month or something where our Broadband
was 40 pound a month on its own before
so we bundle it all together and it
saved a lot of money
um and I was simple but I was thinking
about get rid of it because now they've
got this thing called Sky glass which is
you get a TV and you get the broadband
and you get all this and it's about 50
Quid but you don't think I should give
you a TV as part of the thing and it's
basically yeah yeah it's really good
um but it's Sky through the internet so
there's no dish anymore
the problem is my Broadband is so
unreliable
and drops out so much that I'm just
thinking I can't I'm gonna do I'm gonna
be watching TV and all of a sudden I'm
going to be able to bloody watch it
because the Broadband decides not to
work for half an hour
um it's never off now but it's stutters
in it you know I mean
um and I'm just like I don't wanna I
don't wanna do it at the moment but if
my Broadband was more reliable I'd do it
but it's not
um so I just can't don't think I can
quite do it and also then it's pointing
all of the strain on the broadband
isn't it so there's nothing coming
through the dish if the Broadband goes
down I can still watch TV
and it's like
everything but to be fair
the sky this thing we have now more and
more of it is on the Broadband anyway if
you want to watch anything like the
catch up it's got to be downloaded it
all comes through the internet so then I
think maybe I should just
the problem with cable is it's got to be
affordable it's got to be reliable
um and it's got to have enough to it I
don't want to see 500 channels anymore
you want to see a much more focused
200 channels or
12 streaming services for cable is cable
going to be what Amazon Prime is trying
to kind of do or or a lot of these
different kind of places where their
their hubs cable could immediately swoop
that out from Amazon and just say hey
you were born and raised with all this
or you were raised with all this or you
might have been born into it and not
remember it necessarily but guess what
cable's still a big part of life so come
on back come on come back to us well
it's still the biggest provider isn't it
is it like 60 or something if Americans
still watch all this TV through cable I
believe so something like that I looked
into um about a year ago when I was
doing a video for something
um and
um
hey I'm sure it was something like that
um but also the thing is with
um the Crunch and everybody's trying to
spend less money one of the things
people say that they was just they were
just reverting back to cable because
that's what they know so they were just
they were just getting rid of the
streamers it was just
um
it's Health Training Services go to
cable
yep
they thought it was going to be 50 50
within a couple of years I believe but
um that might might have changed now but
yeah if streaming services if so if if
the cable services start throwing in the
biggest
streaming services as part of the deal
they'll doubt that become the normal
because the infrastructure's there is
the the Technologies already there and
people have already got it in their
homes and it's reliable so
if it's cheaper people will do it that's
kind of what I'm thinking it's I mean I
was kind of excited the last
five eight ten years I mean that's kind
of like my my young young adult kind of
growth period in life I was like oh I
get to be part of this new age of TV and
all this kind of stuff and it's been fun
and I don't know if it was a pandemic or
what but that
wave of TV kind of feels over in a way
even though we still get last of us we
still get half of the Dragon we still
get Ahsoka which was
amazing yesterday it was yeah other than
the end
spiced whales really
oh oh that was oh are you
the pergol or the best thing in the
freaking world I love The Purge I love
the Pergo
love the purple
right okay we had this in Star Trek and
they had a bunch of space babies
um and then that was stupid I I didn't
like that I thought it was ridiculous
the rest of the episode was great what
about them was uh
uh I guess there's space whales that can
travel between galaxies
well that's that's what inspired
hyperdrives way back when
what why
not necessarily but that's a good
prevailing idea of thought uh you just
bent over and pulled that out of your
ass possibly but I I have heard it
mentioned before not from any actual
Creator this this weird crap in nature
then then that's the only way to crap in
space at whales that can
do that but you know let's go find real
space whales I'm just I'd like to find
some you've got that zombie ant and as
soon as you learn about things like the
zombie and everything else makes
complete sense
the rules go out the window as soon as
you think things like that so
yeah no I I guess I literally finished
Rebels
two minutes before I started my re-watch
of rebels I finished two minutes prior
to starting the new episode of Ahsoka
which was
perfectly and yeah they were in Rebels
they were great they're they're like
tardigrades but for space in a certain
way you know that's a Star Trek
reference
and there are these um and then we had
this like um the discovery can go
anywhere in the universe instantly
following these using a Spore drive
because there's these mushrooms in space
and they just have these spores
everywhere and the tardigrades could
navigate it so they could just jump in
and out wherever they wanted to and it
was um
the stupidest thing
I can't I kind of like it does that mean
like the mycelium would be talking to
each other from far
distances and the yeah
I wouldn't think about it too much about
your brain
I don't dislike the idea though but I
don't necessarily like it with normal
technology it'd have to be like some
weird biotech or something
it was supposed to be like weird
technology that was yeah but you know it
was just stupid honestly it was the most
ridiculous idea and the technology that
the Federation just forgot about
as well
you won't bother huh uh but no I would
not want to be under a space whale when
they they need to go
um
that'd be terrifying but and also would
be very terrifying because in Rebels it
has shown that they eat gas so the same
thing that like we fuel our tanks to fly
around the Galaxy either Star Wars
Galaxy with is the same thing that the
Pergo are eating which probably allows
them to hyper jump like the way they do
so yeah
while they're going to the bathroom
would not be a good idea yeah all right
might be a little fire talk about a
blowhole man that'd be a
that would not be enjoyable there but I
just I love the concept of them that
they're this like ancient kind of
creature and they're they're very
whale-like in the sense of whales on
Earth are way smarter than we ever give
them credit for they're what far more
intelligent than we can even understand
we can't even understand them we know
they have language we know they have
history to a degree we know they're
smart
kind of same thing with with the space
wheel I don't know I'm uh
all day I I I I'm not a big Star Wars
fan in Star Trek we've got space
creatures as well
um there's an episode of great episode
of The Next Generation called tin man
where there was this ancient space
creature and it could travel at warp or
whatever it looked like a giant seed
um but I it just it just smacked me as
stupid but I'm not the Star Wars fan you
are so
well I think most of these folk are
forgetting this is Space Opera a space
fantasy this is not sci-fi it's not like
oh yeah no no I feel pain
in the second episode that woman punched
a robot and it went oh and I'm like
and so I made a comment on our little
group dinner I went if they always felt
pain yeah that's Star Wars oh so Star
Wars has always been stupid is what
you're saying and story was like yeah
it's meant for 12 year old boys
people forget that they put themselves
in it so much and it's just like you
forget you're not necessarily the
audience for this as well and it's it's
supposed to be a fun thing for all ages
it's a family thing it's if it were if
it were badass sci-fi which it does lean
into occasionally we would have a lot
more they're already a good amount of
decapitations hand hand cut offs and
things like that there would be a lot
more of those where there are some now
there would be about
we're going to go a bit grittier I think
uh
be in this didn't we it wasn't a
surprise no no he was in the trailer
okay that's good because I knew about
that months ago and I and that's what I
thought everyone knew and then I saw a
couple of people oh my God it was
amazing I don't know and I was just like
oh [__] did I have a big spoiler that I
didn't tell anyone so don't do that so I
get told things sometimes and I don't
care so I don't tell anyone
uh
but anyway yeah no it's I I loved it 12
year old girls now damn canucker that's
I that that
whatever yeah it's 12 year old boys 12
year old girls and 12 year olds well no
George Lucas wrote uh a movie for 12
year old girls and he produced it and it
did not do very well it was a little
animated one that I think from 2005-ish
2007 not 2005. that's Revenge of the
Sith I think it was 2008-ish 10ish
something like that uh
and that's quite the accomplishment
people like to be pissy I I forget that
sometimes some people are just
inherently not happy with life and they
like to put that out there
it's stupid
it's fantasy it's sci-fi stupid isn't
necessarily A Bad Thing and at the end
of the day it wasn't a big dragon thing
eating a child and then spitting it out
several days later and it being fine
that was stupid yeah capital
italics bold and that one was done with
me
in the meticulous beautiful Artful and
it was years in the making
but if you didn't watch Rebels you
wouldn't know that so go watch Robots
is garbage for children I kind of want
to block this dude
you don't want to talk about this don't
talk about it uh yeah he's gonna have an
opinion it's fine of course but we're
excited about it wrong everyone could be
wrong of course you don't have to negate
other people's excitement about things
though that's that's that's stupid that
is stupid uh did I hear correctly about
Snow White going straight to Disney Plus
I'm not sure about that I would not be
surprised I kind of hope
I'm kind of hoping it it doesn't get
released and Disney's like let's take
that profit back and and write it off
kind of deal uh
[Music]
I
forget who's moderating
I I we have a moderators in here I don't
know how to do all that match fancy he's
he's The Tech Guys
I'll just say he's a moderator I think
so she can so just
use the magic yes yes yes
to put him in a Timeout for five minutes
uh I'm just saying my friends that's all
I use the forces
uh
uh we were talking about Disney and
cable and then we got on Star Wars from
Disney and cable yeah but shall we end
it with a different Disney property that
has now voted to or has had one of their
most
frivolous and large
aspects that make them work that they
have been neglecting for years and years
and years
vote to unionize or join a union
do you know what they've done there
though
they've basically made the CGI companies
around the rest of the world very very
happy
very very they're going to be busy
because Hollywood will just go oh right
okay so in Hollywood all of our CGI
workers now unionized
um
India's got some really brilliant CGI
engineers
let's do that
they show the people doing all the uh
the the Bollywood and tollywood movies
right now are about to get hired
I'm Europe as well there's loads of
really great CGI companies in Britain
Germany
um uh there's a there's a big tech
company for the big tech companies in
Holland whatever they're going to get
busy I I just I hope they don't I hope
the union just allows them to
um
get what they deserve because then they
work hard and they've been seriously
overworked and that has shown in the end
product that they've been overdown
worked
um but in all honesty what will happen
is they'll go abroad and they'll pay
Pence on the dollar
I think so I I I I like the idea of it a
lot I think it
is necessary that they are treated in a
different way than they have been and
not overworked to the degree they have
been as well they I mean Marvel
literally fired someone who's been there
since day one with Kevin [__] at the
end of last year the one of his two top
lieutenants like if Kevin value were to
retire and be like not necessarily
retire but say all right I'm done with
the MCU one of the two people that would
have been like all right let me put my
name in the cap
she gone
because she was not handling all this
correctly and now
it's seemingly because of that or at
least partially because of that
here we go would you argue though that
the whole strike issue is actually going
to be very good for entertainment
Industries around the rest of the world
it's not just going to be the CGI and
everything else I actually think we're
already seeing
big Productions go around the world
is this just going to accelerate it
that's that's
part of me is
excited and part of me is terrified I
guess I'm kind of I I like earlier I
needed the debunk Theory and I need the
full biased alien Theory and then we'll
meet in the middle somewhere but then
the TV shows are made all over the world
and then
um and
um we're seeing places like Nigeria and
things like this having just like really
thriving TV and movie production
facilities
um India China That's So China let's not
let's not ships to China because then
anything that gets made has to be
favorable towards the Chinese government
and we don't need that the CCP has
screwed up film
as a whole very bad for Hollywood yes
uh you're all right secretary
real quick real quick just just so we
can put it in the past real fast I just
can't believe there are adults that take
Star Wars base Wheels seriously I don't
think anyone's really taking it
seriously it's literally us just
enjoying something from our childhood I
think you're the only one taking this
seriously my friend like Rebels is a
cartoon we're just having fun and
enjoying a space fantasy we're not
trying to take it seriously
I wasn't gonna block you I never was I I
don't believe in blocking people like
that I really don't I I wasn't but we
can't we don't know how to do it anyway
but but that's the thing I we're not
taking it seriously it's just it's
literally a fun thing meant for children
that we can enjoy as an adult when we go
back into a childlike frame of mind it's
not something that's like it's not
sci-fi it's not I want this to make
sense and I'm gonna be pissed off if it
doesn't make sense within the laws of
physics it's a space fantasy it's stupid
anyway it's okay that it's stupid it's
lovably stupid it's like it's like
lovable oafs in Star Wars is full of
them that's one of the best parts
um um I actually do know to block you
but it's fine I am the only ones because
you know Casey and we get like we don't
get them very much anymore
I'll get rid of them pretty quick but
yeah you just click on the three dots
and put the person in time actual band
they are real
but I don't know I need
I need a debunk Theory as well then
we'll meet in the middle yeah I'm gonna
ride on the back of one going yeah with
your cowboy hat yeah
you know how excited I would be I would
I wouldn't think I would ever stop
smiling
pretty sure I would just be stuck on the
oil
um
um the VFX house though that they're
going back to that because they're the
people that would be they're the same
Studios I guess actually no lucasfilm
has their own in-house studio so they're
not necessarily the same people Marvel's
working with but Marvel I feel like will
end up
going like you just said I thought that
was going to come up in the conversation
later but you you hit the nail on the
head uh they're gonna go to Bollywood
they're gonna go to Hollywood they're
going to Nollywood Nigeria is the
fastest growing country in the world and
it is also the fastest growing film
aspect of anything in the world which is
crazy uh it seems like
tall I mean bollywood's not necessarily
so much film oriented that's more
um tollywood per se tollywood and
Nollywood I think are the the best spots
for creativity in the world at the
moment which hurts Hollywood which kind
of sucks because I live here I moved
here to do something very specific and
this is that place in the world that's
good for that but
is lose in its magic you can feel it
people can feel it everywhere
that's it Britain has been making most
of these films for Years anyway a lot of
the Marvel movies were shot here
um Ireland Britain New Zealand at least
these things are made all over the world
um there are big effects company we
again go back to Stargate the rumor is
the effects company that's go go was
going to be doing it before everything
went put on pause was German
and a lot of there's a big German tech
company in there well ahead of most the
world in lots of things so
excuse me
um
it's just you know
that's just the way of things and my
only worry is that I I've said this on
live streams before the car we used to
have a really good car industry in the
UK we kept going on strike we now don't
have a car industry in the UK that's
what Hollywood is at risk that that's
the risk for Hollywood that actually the
big studios will just go we don't need
you
they need big A-list actors at the
moment they need those actors they do
the rest of them they don't need it
let's go abroad I I don't I would I
would kind of caveat and say they might
not even need the A-list actors that was
something that we've talked about the
last kind of year or two Anthony Mackey
kind of brought it to a lot of people's
attention was
hey I'm not a movie star I'm just the
Falcon people know the Falcon they know
Captain America they don't know Anthony
Mackey people I mean Chris Evans and the
Chris's are kind of like the New Age
movie stars
but even I mean look at the extraction
two numbers it did well but
go go down the street and ask how many
people watched it
it might be two out of ten Netflix will
never tell us but it's actually really
good I really enjoy
um
I know you like this one but I I didn't
watch it because it did not get the best
of reviews from audience or critics was
ghosted the Chris Evans and Anna De
armas on Apple
action movie oh yeah good
yeah I enjoyed it it's good I just like
even that so it didn't get eyes you know
there weren't very many people that
viewed it so because it's on Apple
it would attract them nonetheless I
think
two uh but I think we just don't have
the movie star like we used to and I I
think that might really hurt
it might be the perfect storm where the
lack of a movie star the strikes
happening and then smaller Studios and
Studios outside of Hollywood are still
able to work
yeah it might turn the industry
completely on its head and it's fine
because you've got Britain and we
actually like develop actors that can
act
so
um that's a bonus
you tell me one of the best actors in
the world right now that isn't British
you're watching only murders in the
building right now there's five there's
six oh there Paul Rudd Paul Roots is he
not a proper actor I'm missing anything
how much Shakespeare is he gonna do come
on
he can do Shakespeare if he wants to did
you not see I mean he's he definitely
leans into funny but he can do serious
he's great
the bear has been poked
it's always worse Texan actors you tell
me one good Texan actor foreign
Texan by the way Texas
by the way is that how people from Texas
prancing
how else would we I heard somebody
pronounce it really weird like Tejas or
something oh well chaos is the
the original version It's the Mexican
version the Hispanic Spanish language
version
Alice Tejas no Tejas oh I tell you what
it was it was Tenacious D and them drank
black and they're touring and they kept
telling all the cities and they kept
saying Tejas and I'm like where's he
coming let's just telling us Place
saying that outside of Texas
probably be a little weird unless you're
like super South near Mexico kind of
region
um
in the Spanish language the x is kind of
pronounced like a huh so it's kind of
same thing but also there when it's
Tejas it's t-e-j-a-s instead of X
whenever you're really saying it like
Tahoe and place it on that one yeah
yeah
not at all
um I I do have to call it an evening I'm
sorry because I've got quite an
important meeting
um
um that we will tell you about in the
coming weeks on side track but
you're all going to be very very happy
if it all comes together everyone is
going to be very very happy
so when it all comes together if it all
comes together let's go with the big if
I could still put my foot in my
proverbial mouth and screw it all up and
we all know the chances of that are
better than 50 50. so
if you put your foot in the mouth as
long as it's like coming from the front
and you get like the toe in there all
you got to do is get your teeth rip open
the hole and you can still speak out of
the bottom of that shoe I'm just saying
well I'm imagining a boot Matt's there
to stop me so that's gonna be there to
hold my hand and make sure that's
something too stupid
fingers crossed people we're going to be
very very happy but I do have to call it
an evening sir yes but we cook at
everything
I believe we have those were our three
main topics
um if you got any final thoughts in
Aliens unions or cable I need a Wii ah
that sounds like a good cable
that's how all of our best videos end
with me the one good thing about cable
coming back is there will be built-in P
breaks again
yeah that's it and and we can get back
to TV that actually makes sense but yeah
it was a great stream I'll I'll hang
just for a couple minutes uh if you want
to chat in in the chat chat uh and leave
it on Side Track mate you're right just
just because you'll get more views so
yeah and I will guys I will see you
tomorrow I'm gonna be doing a live
tomorrow afternoon just to talk about
the video I've got going on tomorrow so
I'll see you tomorrow
see ya
who who that's that's that's a lot of me
right there let's go let's go right
there all right what are we thinking
what are we thinking aliens are but far
far doubts of them arriving
hold up let me let me decipher that
aliens are but far far
down to them arriving you believe aliens
are
existent
but they are far far away
and you don't think they're going to
come here so do you subscribe to the
thought process or the concept of us
being in a dark force the human
civilization that we're in a dark force
technically in space yeah would that
would that be right where we are
of course an intelligent species
I'm back on here just so he can do some
funny things
down there I was like how do I do it how
do I mess with him don't forget to go
over to M cubed And subscribe from next
week we're only going to be on M Cubed
on a Wednesday talking all of this stuff
so if you want to join us you have to go
and subscribe to M cubed
as soon as I had my Wii my brain came
back and I remembered we hadn't done
that well see um Matt made me all the
fancy little banners and stuff for it
and I need to add them onto this part as
well I forget things
um next week your permission
it will be a Stargate video because I've
got an idea but we'll talk about it next
week so we'll
see you Sunday and see you next week on
mqd sounds like a plan
bye
Stargate I'm in that's all you had to
say I'm in just a quick sexy pose
and I'm out of here
there it goes J our system is Tiny or
our solar system is Tiny in the galaxy
and one thousands yeah yeah I I think
I think the Dark Forest is
if if if I had to try to
subscribe to something instead of just
kind of being all like well sure yeah
maybe possibly
I would think
we might be in a dark Forest
hopefully of course I still want aliens
to like be visiting us that'd be cool
that'd be really nice
um
maybe not really nice it could be kind
of scary
but I would I would I I would still want
that to maybe be a thing I'd still like
maybe there'd be more out there that we
are interacting with that maybe the
public doesn't necessarily know about
all that kind of stuff that'd be really
cool it'd be cool if we could Advance
our civilization and do all kinds of
cool stuff right
if we're in a dark Forest that makes
things harder I think maybe that if
we're in a dark Forest there might be
some people able to get through that
dark Forest there might be other
intelligent civilizations that have
gotten through that dark forest in the
past and
have tried to get back there might be
some that are trying to get back
constantly
I'm not sure that's that's what I would
like to think because I really do like
the idea of the dark force where maybe
since our galaxy is a little smaller
than a lot and we're so just kind of out
there and we're not near too many other
galaxies
I mean we're near plenty but like it's
harder to get to us maybe they struggle
to get to us maybe if we want to bring
it back to Star Wars Rebels sorry
circuitry uh
they use the force to bring them through
a little like bit of wild space at a
certain point to bring the lasat species
back to its home home planet
if there was and they have trouble
getting there because of like their
solar flares and there's all kinds of
different things that keep them from
getting there if
we have something similar that just
makes it hard to navigate not
necessarily solar flares aren't even a
sort but something that just makes it
hard to get to our planet that would
make sense that makes sense to me
because if there is an intelligent life
why wouldn't we have heard from it why
wouldn't I mean there's so many little
things but that might give a little more
validity to there have been some in the
past there are some now possibly there
could be some in the future
um that doesn't necessarily address
interdimensional kind of things so I'm
not entirely sure
but
because because aliens could be a whole
inter-dimensional aspect of things and
that that changes the conversation
almost entirely
ish ah work yes yes
um doesn't seem like it should be hard
to verify Mexico's claims then we don't
have to speculate that's a great Point
that's a great point
excuse me with with the DNA already been
taken out of the aliens quote unquote
and it
be not human
is it close enough to like a a genome of
a human's that it might be a pygmy of
sort that like was a small population of
like a subspecies of human that died out
a thousand years ago 1200 years ago or
dude we got an alien on our hands I I if
if the DNA doesn't fit that's that's
kind of the damning or not necessarily
damning but the
the um the thing that it raises our
inquisitiveness that much more
because I love love for that to be the
case
and then they actually are aliens but
then it actually raises
dozens more questions of course
I haven't heard enough and obviously I I
got a little spanglished down but I
don't know Spanish enough I want to read
and I want to read the captions from the
actual I guess video released from the
Mexican Government to
hear what was legitimately said here
like I guess the the facts that were
presented and stuff like that sorry I
was behind all cut up
uh ancient humans sent the asteroid to
Kill the Dinosaurs so they could
colonize the Earth because we [__] up
Mars our original Homeworld
is that the next Roland Limerick movie
um because I'm in I'm totally in
um real quick let me catch up unless
Humanity can either solve the light
speed limit or find a wormhole solution
such as a Stargate we were limited to
exploding a small portion of our galaxy
perhaps an alien race will do so
yeah definitely possible so I know
sci-fi is going to love this this little
nod but we've been playing Star field on
g-cubed a whole bunch so don't forget to
subscribe there actually let me put that
right here because it's just us right
now so we'll toss this on there
um
Starfield has a gravity drive that
gravity jumps and
I like that idea a lot but it would we'd
either have to solve light speed find a
wormhole solution similar to a gravity
Drive solution essentially a wormhole
just done in a little bit different way
I guess uh
or maybe an alien civilization could
help us I don't know Harris you could
type the words into Google Translate to
see what it says in English
we uh
yeah
but that's Spanish is a romance language
and everything it says is not
necessarily exactly what it means
because it could be a little more
metaphorical than the literal
translation
I don't know that Google translate
doesn't work super well with a lot of
languages
and I'm uh but that's also I'd have to
type up or copy and paste the entire
transcript I'm just trying to watch the
video and have a have the subtitles be
in a different language
um but it would and I know Spanish I
know the the rules to the language
enough where I could go back into Google
translate and probably make some sense
of it um I just would like to see I I
would like to see the English subtitles
coming from
the Spanish company that probably aired
the video if that makes sense so the
English subtitles come from a Spanish
speaker's mind and not necessarily an
English speaker's mind translating with
Spanish I'd like a Spanish speaker to
translate it in English if that makes
more sense just I feel like it would
be a little less Lost in Translation at
that point which would be nice which
would be nice okay real quick did I miss
anything else back here does it seem
like it should be hard okay that was the
where we started if we were in a dark
Forest turn the bloody torch on us
I mean
we did though we turned the torch on by
sending radio signals out everywhere and
that's one of those things at least in
the last 50 60 years
we've had radio signals just maybe
closer to 70 80 years now
we've had radio signals just going out
into the ether going out into the void
going out into the deep darkness of
space
what's gonna answer
who did we send those out to and why did
we send them out in general just for the
sake of sending them out originally I
know that was kind of like the idea of
like Time Capsule of our planet that's
that's sounds kind of sad though like
we're not going to be here or something
like that
hopefully we still are
I'd like to have all languages beamed
into my mind don't know that don't uh
don't know which one heard Starfield is
a mix of SG and corrector no
um
Starfield feels like
just while we're on that real quick
you humans are so noisy drawing
attention to yourselves more and more if
it's really 30 unknown DNA there's a way
there's no way it's human of any kind
that is true if it's really 30 percent
I mean we have denisovians we have the
dragon man which is another human
humanoid species that we found on the
planet we have neanderthals could that
30 DNA be something similar hominid not
necessarily Homo Sapien or homo
something but a Homa nid
um
sure Cube fall off signals you wouldn't
see a torch dining on the moon ah yeah
yeah but but we sent out like the torch
that we've sent out was more so
radio signal signals signals whatever's
the worst
we're a Sci-Fi oriented kind of group of
folk we can figure out a good
word used for sign what did I say
significant significant I don't know
well I was trying to make a cool word up
right there I'm not Shakespeare I ain't
that fancy but missing link uh fix that
blood chain hey that's interesting I
heard it was like Star Trek or Star Wars
I believe okay real quick back on
Starfield
um I would actually put it closer to the
expanse
it feels much more so like the expanse
mixed in with the ability to
jump
it almost feels star warsy in the jump
aspect it's like a hyperdrive but it's
it's the grab drive like we talked about
uh so it's not a hyperdrive just
shooting them out there it is there's a
technical explanation for it which is
pretty cool no one has TVs that could
receive the signal anymore why would
aliens that's also a great Point aliens
might not even have technology that can
understand what
we're sending out there
so we may have sent out this torch
technically but will people actually see
it and can they see it through the Dark
Forest or are they just getting glimpses
of something people are big mad over
that game ah maybe people are big happy
over that game too and
I'm more of the big happy aspect of it I
played for an hour yesterday I usually
play for a lot more but it's just it's a
fun game
um now on alien ship collides with
Voyager 2 and crashes now we have the
tech
hmm I mean there's so many little
different things that could happen or
may have happened that
ad validity or subtract validity to
theories conspiracies etc etc
I just don't know what to think I do
really like the Dark Forest idea if if I
personally have to subscribe to
something I'm thinking we're in a dark
Forest we might have seen all these
signals out there we've probably been
visited before by people that were
either lost or or stuck or trying to
take a break on the way somewhere else
who knows uh was it sci-fi Quest or was
it Brett's build somebody said it
earlier
um they came uh they need to go to the
bathroom so they made a bathroom stop on
Earth and they got stuck which is kind
of like well that that could have
happened it legitimately could have
happened
so I don't I don't know what to believe
I don't I'm really not sure and that's
kind of half the fun in it is that we
get to kind of just decipher all these
little bits of information that are just
given to us over time
but the Battlestar galactive found Earth
in 1980.
a Voyager 2 has been traveling for 40
years and there's only 0.002 percent of
the light year away
but it was traveling with technology we
had 40 years ago
if if we were to send something out now
would it catch up and how quickly would
it catch up howdy stranger times I know
stranger times one of Shelly's favorite
things in the world and paranormal stuff
is great so if you're a big paranormal
fan
stranger times is the place to be y'all
know y'all know but any hominid would
have over 90 identical okay okay
um I wasn't entirely sure on that that
makes sense though
so if it's 30
non-human DNA what do we have here what
do we have
I want to know I want to know uh of
course and hello hello it always makes
me happy I hear people saying hello
Steve my dad's name is Steve too I'm
like hey it always cracks me up uh you
can be my my British dad from afar uh 30
kilometers
it's only 30 kilometers
wait wait wait wait wait wait it's it's
you're joking right it's gone more than
30 kilometers we can catch up to that
quickly nowadays that wouldn't even be a
mammal right like
right I I'm sure it's more than that let
me let me Google it I got the fancy
laptop in front of me how far has the
Voyager
traveled is it gonna just give me
voyager one or one and two Voyager one
has reached a distance of
23.381 billion kilometers or 14.528
billion miles from Earth and 24.483
billion kilometers 14.592 million
billion miles excuse me from the Sun
okay interesting that's the first one
though Voyager two let me type that one
in 12 billion
spacecraft is now in its extended
mission of studying Interstellar space
it's been operating for 46 years in 21
days as of September 11 2023 so two days
ago
um as of August 2023 it has reached a
distance of 134 a.u 20 billion
kilometers 12 billion miles from Earth
all right that that that seems a little
bit that makes more sense 30 kilometers
per second oh okay I got off screen or I
would have seen that oops that makes a
lot more sense
one of my favorite missions in Stargate
that we've Stargate sorry star field
that we've played so far sci-fi Quest
would remember this one it was one of
the earlier ones that was kind of
intriguing you just kind of hopped up on
this planet and were like interesting
there was an old spaceship from Earth
that was sent and has been traveling
with the generational ship and had
traveled over 200 years to get to this
planet that when they show up their Tech
interesting enough their technology is
so mundane and out of date that the new
technologies that the humans that
surpassed them and jump past them after
the grab Drive was invented are now down
on this planet and it's it's a planet
that's used as like it's it's the Vegas
of
the solar systems essentially a couple
different solar systems it's essentially
a resort planet and this whole 200 year
old plus Generation ship that has had
countless numbers of people come and and
just grow on it and be excited to
finally reach this destination get there
they can't even contact the people on
the planet
and you have to kind of figure out a
little work around all of it and there
are a couple different ways you can do
it it is decision based so that's that's
fun that's really good aspect of the
game but I'd like that idea of
if we send the Voyager in Voyager 2
these plate to these different places
what's stopping us from if we start
using nuclear energy in our
spaceships if if we find a way to
actually do a grab jump a hyper jump
Wormhole jump however we want to
actually title it as
we're gonna just jump way past these
people 163 kilometers per second is the
fastest vehicle so far
is is that in space or on on Earth with
gravity and acted on it
because if it's in space technically
that could go faster but we'd have to
figure out a way to
we would have to figure out a few
different things for that honestly
um these science types claim to be smart
get these aliens to some top scientist
and broadcast it live when the whole
world knows it once
um
yeah
because that's the thing you have a
whole lot of smart people all over this
planet and not all of them are going to
agree on certain things there's going to
be a whole
multitude of things to disagree about or
at least question each other about
in one way to
one way to not do that is to have it
live streamed the entire time but
scientists don't necessarily want their
work live streamed obviously this is
this is fun stuff to live stream that
would be really interesting for the
human species to have live stream but
who's going to work under those
conditions and also what government
would allow that to happen
because they don't know what's going to
happen either and that's the only issue
I guess there is what government would
sign off on that
as great of an idea as it is for the
human species probably making us feel
closer as a species and and really maybe
realigning Humanity together in a lot of
ways
it might not happen because governments
want that kind of control and that power
and wouldn't let that kind of stuff out
there or at least be that transparent to
everybody and if they were that
transparent to everybody what's stopping
another government from coming in there
and doing a military strike or something
on it shooting the camera they know
where that camera is just because of the
the pinpoint uh or they can pinpoint the
location of the area from the stream
eventually pretty simply I would think
was modern technology and if it's a
government organization they can figure
that out
and why wouldn't they go take that why
wouldn't they go take it out they don't
want there's I'm sure there's a lot of
people on this planet that are in charge
that don't necessarily want some things
to get out there and that would be one
of those things that's like very very
hesitant uh I'm alien a special species
uh real quick real quick back surprise
meeting with boss ooh good meeting bad
meeting hopefully good meeting see you
said Sabine I thought we were going back
to Star Wars so being hostenfelder is a
fantastic YouTube educator who debunks a
lot of rubbish from mainstream media ooh
I'm writing that name down core or crew
is really good at debunking stuff as
well and I'm I'm not like there for the
debunking stuff but I want to have a
full picture before a thought can
actually be formed you know was okay
meeting normal good good okay real quick
Sabine hassenfelder
Sabine
hassenfelder
blue yeah got it written down that's
that's interesting so my understanding
is there's nothing on this Earth that is
more than 15 different from our DNA so
30 definitely means alien that's a good
point I didn't even think about that duh
duh like we're we're more closely
related to like birds and crabs
obviously and then like there's
different levels but the furthest thing
we're not related to is like 15 away
it's like 10 12 15 maybe a little more
maybe a little less but
definitely I like Sabine too so beans
great
[Music]
um
real quick Guardians of the Galaxy 3
when they land and drags through the
ball
oh at the kid at the kid's head do you
think that would happen here that'd be
kind of funny
um what about Maya she's kind of like a
space whale I'm not familiar or Moya
who's Moya
oh I just got a whole bunch of different
people popping up on Google
I I'm not familiar with Moya
um she's a theoretical physicist is that
Moya or Sabine
confirmation for bacteria or or similar
contamination from bacteria are similar
oh okay okay that could make sense
Farscape okay okay that makes sense
I've watched the first three episodes of
Farscape and then
I decided to watch I I really liked it
actually but I I wanted to watch
Stargate so much of the time I decided
to watch moya's Farscape okay
um I decided to watch Stargate instead
and I haven't watched Farscape since
seen the first three episodes I would
have to re-watch those first three
episodes but it's something I do really
want to watch
oh oh what's what's that that question
if I'll believe aliens are visiting when
they abduct Me In oh God I should have
should have um finished Moya is the
spaceship okay uh I just remember I
loved
Claudia Black's character I wanted to
color Val for a second I love Claudia's
Claudia Black's character there I loved
the uh the big dude the the big puppet
the the angry puppet he was he was good
and then the little tiny guy was great I
don't remember their names but I do
really want to actually catch up on
Farscape that'd be a good thing to catch
up on
but Stargate and you all know I I love
Stargate I I I thought I was gonna like
it so much that I started watching it
instead of watching Farscape
and look two years later here we are
talking about Stargate all the time
weekly uh sometimes daily
and I wouldn't have it another way
because I love me some Stargate it's
it's great but I I really should catch
up in Farscape I should catch up in
Battlestar Galactica and a couple others
as well they're all great
um but yeah we're about an hour and a
half into here I might start heading out
of here do we have anything else we want
to just talk about hang out I can hang
out for another 10 15 if we really want
to
um but yeah what are we thinking I
really hope to get abducted but it seems
like they take the weak Skeptics instead
for real like come on get us the good
stuff blinded but oh no no no no I was
Pro
I want Robert Carlisle back in Stargate
he he died really quickly even if not
SGU
he could be an alien could we get Robert
Carlisle as an alien that'd be really
nice
I okay
we've got Robert Carlisle and SGU for
just a little bit but you know who I
really want that was also a kernel in
Stargate is Michael Rooker played a
freaking Colonel I think was it season
eight season nine of Stargate they're
off-world in one and he's like the
colonel of one of like the alpha sites
doesn't show him dying or anything like
that so Michael Rooker could be there
and you want to bring it back to
guardians of galaxy or Walking Dead I
love me some Merle love love me some
Michael Rooker no matter what he's great
isn't Carl busy with the full monty TV
show
uh
uh right you said Carlisle my brain went
to Robert Patrick I I was thinking I was
picturing Robert Patrick from Terminator
who's also in the first two episodes of
SGU
um Carlisle is doing the full Monster TV
show right now but I I if he's offered
Stargate I'm pretty sure he'd come back
to Stargate in a heartbeat over that
um hello alien world Airsoft I like that
name that's cool
um Doctor Who is affected by the strikes
but only in America the actors can't
promote It In America which could hurt
its Disney plus 60th anniversary special
International awesomeness in November
yeah yeah that could hurt I'm not the
biggest Doctor Who guys so
I'm not like
super familiar with everything but um
yeah you said yes he would hi there
alien world anyone understand the puddle
jumper and Stargate looks kind of like
the Tic Tac UFO
kind of ooh oohs um real quick let me
let me scroll back up there's a a
comment that was on the side Trek
can I bring up Sidetrack on Facebook
over here hold up
I really really really like this theory
that the
oh
maybe I won't be able to bring it up
I'll I'll try to I'll try to memorize it
and then bring it back from there uh I
meant to write exploding not exploding
to get exploding not exploding the near
Galaxy it is interesting that the recent
Sci-Fi show The Arc has human space
Travelers blow up a planet orbiting
Proxima Centauri while terraforming
yeah interesting is the ark worth of
viewing uh I'm I'm I've debated it for a
little while is it worth the viewing
because it seems pretty cool but also it
seems
not the best made product I guess is the
easiest way of putting that but I'm I'm
intrigued exploring yes yes yes yes uh
without the booster Engine things
extended the way the puddle jumper looks
when it goes to the Stargate yeah no it
looks very much looks like a Tic Tac so
the really cool I I wish let me let me
okay I'm gonna think about it and I'm
gonna try to find it on my phone while
we're talking here so
in Sidetrack the other day I believe it
was a it was a lady I believe and she
posted
about
a theory she had here it is it was
Adrian Carter so that could be a girl or
a guy
um here here's the theory this post on
the Sidetrack Facebook group y'all go
check it out the one where it has Matt
from SGU and then it has a bunch of
priors and orai over here yes here it is
here's it is Google it then click image
up top find it visually I was trying to
but I have to like log back in through
Facebook and all that because I'm on a
different tab or a different
Chrome
that tab a different
I I have different
Chrome's open up and then I have
different tabs on each one like I have a
different Google account have different
Chrome's open up if that makes sense so
I'm on them Cube stuff right now not
like my personal stuff which is why my
Facebook isn't just popping up
um The Arc six out of 10 for me is worth
a look ah
okay so let me read y'all this real
quick I really like this Adrian Carter
put it in the side track Facebook group
which if you're not a part of come on
come on come on Facebook Etc it's pretty
simple to find anyway this is the the
thought Stargate Theory here we go hi
everyone I'm new to the group and would
love to get your thoughts on this as I
know the group would have a uh has a lot
of love for Stargate I found a giant
hidden Easter egg in Stargate and I
think it might have been the plot for
Stargate Universe and his third fourth
and fifth Seasons that were originally
planned in season 9 episode 3 of sg1
titled origin there's a prior teachingly
background teaching in the background
from the book of origin he's reading a
story and he says as he lay there die in
the Sun the Sands of the desert all
around him Petrus spoke to the Rock not
with his lips but with his mind and The
Rock wept tears of fresh water and his
thirst was quenched now this sounds
extremely similar to the SGU episode air
part 3 where Matt is on the desert
Planet dying in the sun unconscious when
he's dreaming hallucinating and the
alien creatures somehow in his
hallucination talking to him
after his hallucination while he's on
the floor
water Springs from the desert sand and
saves his life now the big question here
is why is Matt's story in the book of
origin even though it was written long
before the events of SGU
that in general I just love that theory
a lot the beachhead episode yeah it was
it was I mean I I was a fan of the
episode in general just for the SGU
aspects of it I do like sju a lot but
wow Dan how to type with a vape in hand
um those two non-human bodies released
in the Mexican UFO hearing look just
like the Asgard oh yeah we talked I
think for like a little over half an
hour to start this thing off with it
great it was great talk but uh uh I'm so
excited for just what what that could be
I can't wait to learn more about it more
and more as more things come out
but Adrian's Stargate Theory
I'm a huge fan of no no worries and it's
still there for you whenever you want to
check it up SGA is the greatest I love
SGA of course but I I yeah it's pretty
easy to remember that episode on SGU
it's pretty straightforward
and you wouldn't think about it being
part of the priors in the ori's book of
origin but do you think that has
anything to do with the idea that maybe
SGU could have been a
in in a horseshoe-shaped universe and we
are kind of in a cyclical kind of thing
maybe it doesn't end and it had
something to do with the
beings or or whatever they were that
created
the
I guess the the the things that should
not have been there in SGU all the
things that we were questioning at the
end were like hold up uh who who created
this the creators or whoever you
actually would refer to them as
um I'm gonna have to go to sidetracked
Facebook to check that out yes I think
it's about two days old so go check on
Sidetrack Facebook but it's a really
good little
typed up no it's not expose a little
typed up paragraph I liked it the people
dying one by one freaky yeah just a tad
um the order I were freaky they were
creepy in general just all of them the
followers got way too cultish way too
quickly and obviously you would kind of
become that way if you see a bunch of
people bringing famine and destruction
to your world very simply but still but
still
um I I
like the idea and I think it ropes
Stargate back together as a whole and
keeps keeps a lot of things
complicated but I think it keeps it more
simple in a way where it doesn't
necessarily have to do
they can do Multiverse they could do
time travel and they have done these
things but I think it is simplified in a
way where it's it's it's cyclical
kind of in a Star Wars way where you
know it's like poetry it rhymes with
Star Wars similar things happen time and
time again
because it's the world is cyclical in
nature and that makes sense but does
that make sense in a star field so sorry
the star field start gate World whatever
star we're talking about Star Wars Star
Trek Star field Star Gate we got all of
them all of them on the brain except
Star Trek I don't have that much much on
the brain oops uh hi Sandy Sandy ah
Shelly do we have the both of y'all I
hope y'all are cooking I
also on Facebook Shelly and Sandy are
always cooking up really nice things and
I like to cook a lot so it's I I love
seeing people cook up good food uh we
need more Xenomorphs on our screen we
will get some soon fetty Alvarez's
Aliens film is coming out I think early
2024 mid-2024 it was gonna come out this
year but I'm not
positive
I think I think it might be 2024 or not
this year I think it might have been
coming out this year but there will also
be a
TV show I believe is still being
produced and made and it's a Noah Holly
alien TV show and I freaking love Noah
Holly I Noah Holly is one of my favorite
creators out there in general right now
and he's not someone that has talked
about enough if y'all have never seen
Legion I've
I think it might be the best comic book
TV show ever made
maybe maybe not more so than Watchmen I
think pound per pound Watchman is great
because it's it's one season and it's a
mini series
but
for only being three seasons
legion's amazing what it does and and it
does get very like conceptual and it I
mean it's it's powers and stuff
superhero powers and stuff but it gets
very sci-fi in a in a sense where
there's some timey wimey things going on
there's some very cerebral things going
on with telepathy and
telekinesis and all these different type
of things and that's just kind of part
of the main powers of the character
because you know he is Charles Xavier's
kid these things happen
but Noah Holly made the show Legion and
I am really excited to see what he does
with the alien show him and I'm a big
fan of fetty Alvarez as well I do like
Freddie Alvarez so I'm intrigued we're
oh oh I didn't even I just saw the
Monarch thing I'm excited for this we're
getting a monster for a show too Monarch
Legacy of monsters I'm excited I'm very
excited about that it looks excellent I
think shmook and I were talking about
this the other day for afterthoughts
obviously we're currently doing Ahsoka
what other Aftershock after shots after
thoughts we could take after shots with
afterthoughts that might be a fun little
thing Legion was cut short and it was
uh it's it's one of the best villains as
well I love uh Farooq just so good so
good
um
that's that's what I was saying
afterthoughts though what other
afterthoughts should we do over here on
M Cube schmook and I can do them
together we can do them individually and
have different ones that we kind of jump
at either way we are going to I think
think about the Continental
monarch
I'm iffy about doing Loki if we had
started doing one with Loki season one
I'd be more gung-ho about it but I feel
like we need to start from the get-go
for afterthoughts you know what I mean
um take care hair is up extreme thank
you my friend thank you Brett's builds
we will see you all back here next week
of course and and probably I don't know
if we're gonna do a theater Thursday
we'll either do a theater Thursday or a
film news Friday on M Cube this week so
keep your eyes out for that g-cube
though
we shall be doing star field star field
I know sci-fi Quest was asking about
that earlier we'll do start field this
evening I believe I have a iMac
screening to go see tonight a free iMac
screening for a haunting in Venice and I
don't know if Kenneth branig is going to
show up I would like him too I don't
know if he can show up to this though
with the strikes going on so probably
not usually it would be something that
he would show up to kind of sucks but
hey at least I still get to see the
movie early in an IMAX
and for free in IMAX which is my
favorite part uh any thoughts on
Foundation from
I love Foundation
I've watched the first two episodes of
the new season
and I really liked what I saw
and I keep forgetting about it
I guess Star Wars went on my brain and I
started my Rebels re-watch and I have
been star warsing a lot
I just I keep forgetting about
Foundation I finished what we do in the
shadows only murdered in the building
every week when it comes out I watch it
um Futurama every week when it comes out
I watch it I didn't have my Apple my
Apple had ran out and I guess I never
renewed it or whatever so I had a
put a new card on Apple all that kind of
stuff uh that's what it was I think my
card had expired on Apple at some point
and I had to like just resign up and not
resign up but just you know put a new
card in there do whatever so now I'm I'm
an apple subscriber again and just
because I wasn't watching it as it came
out I kind of got behind on foundation
and I feel bad about getting behind on
Foundation because I love it I have
here
can I let me hold up I'll be I'll be
right back let me 30 seconds and I'm
gonna show you my entire Foundation
collection
oh
foreign
[Music]
how did I make that there were a couple
books that I did not
that I did not
grab because there were just too many
but this is this is the the second half
of some
these are all Isaac Asimov
I don't think you can ever have too many
Isaac Asimov books
because I got plenty
one stack two stacks
all shows need afterthoughts dude yeah I
agree but
like as they come out right should we do
ones that have already aired and it's
like Season Two Season three or
something like that but yeah Lee Pace is
excellent paste is excellent in
everything everything and yeah
there's a lot of books there's a lot of
books I just ran up my my very steep
staircase to go do it my I don't have
the longest staircase I'm I'm the second
story of my my little townhouse here is
where I stay and
my entire staircase leading up to it is
it's very steep
and I've turned it into a bookshelf so I
I have a whole whole lot of books out
there are you Stormy in Disguise no but
story would be proud story would be
proud if I showed him my ads like Isaac
asimov's books stack like this uh he'd
immediately turn around and probably
grab his too which would be pretty funny
but yeah no I I feel like stormy
disguise honestly I'm gonna just keep
the books here so I can have a little
arm rest that's not too shabby for us in
the UK that's the first floor
yeah
I
I'm just gonna did I say the second
floor I meant upstairs
I'm just gonna find grammar like caveats
and try to find a way around it uh but
that honestly that's something I feel
like would be just like it'd be a random
thing to do but it would be a fun little
debate to have like what what is the
ground floor what's the first floor
what's the second floor and when it
comes to a basement is a basement sub
level one or is a basement a basement
and then the ghost cell level one
or is basement sub level one and then
the first floor after that would be
basements or sub level two it'd be
interesting uh
totally unrelated to film or sci-fi but
it would be just a fun little debate to
have
uh I had three or four thousand
paperbacks in my garage no one wanted no
one wanted the I ended up throwing them
away I still feel bad about it all
sci-fi
Peter
I wanted them I wanted them Peter
probably halfway across the world though
so that that might not have worked but
damn that sucks uh
what did you did you just throw them
away or did you give them to like a
Goodwill to give them to like an old
bookstore an old library or something
hopefully they're out there hopefully if
if you just threw them away hopefully
homeless people have become very
educated in the UK
it's in London it's a crime Peter
even the mob apps
out watch out all the book readers are
coming after you uh but you know what I
think Asimov is a good place to end it I
do need to catch up on Foundation the
show
which I think is doing doing justice to
all Isaac Asimov
asimov's Laws of Robotics asthma's laws
of humanity the man was
a genius nothing short of it I tried
some of the hardbacks Charities oh good
good good good
uh that's always great great I bet
someone might have grabbed them at the
dump totally if I would have if I walked
by any trash can and I see like
that many but I'm just gonna start I I
would just start grabbing I would come
back with my car if I don't already have
it and I would just toss them in the
truck and keep driving it'd be great
that'd be a good debate there's a movie
called The 13th floor isn't that
would be the 12th in the UK oh that'd be
okay I'm
I don't know why you're saying that just
made me think of like a fun little movie
that would be
well you could do like a a funny spoof
horror comedy Steve stranger times could
think about this one uh like a horror
comedy where Maybe It's haunting the
13th floor but then you get a British
person come up and you're like well this
is the 12th floor or something like that
and they have to completely like screw I
don't know I'm just I'm I'm spitballing
ideas but that'd be a funny little movie
if done correctly uh any first editions
he was ahead of his time I feel bad not
reading much
hey never feel bad about it there's
there's always books and audio books out
there you know honestly uh I have not
been reading the way I should as of late
for this for this entire year really I
started off last year I read a whole
whole lot and the beginning of this year
I think I was reading a bunch and then I
think my birthday in early February kind
of rolled around and I just haven't been
reading as much as I should since then
for a little over half half the year
knows some rare ones ooh damn did you
keep the rare ones
um or any rare ones I guess there's
actually a haunted hotel that doesn't
have a 13th floor well a lot of hotels
technically don't have 13th floors
but if a person if somebody from the UK
comes in and says well this is
technically the 13th floor I don't know
that I I feel like there's some comedy
gold in there somewhere
I haven't thought much of it through
though you you'll saw my my thinking
through at the moment and it was about
20 seconds of just
huh and then piecing something together
in the brain
um
but yeah no no reading I think is
something that's
not gone out of style per se but it's
something that not as many people do as
they ever have and I think that that's
kind of a you know that might there
might be a caveat to that as well as
there are more people than there ever
have been so maybe there are more
readers than there ever have been but we
just don't know because it feels like
less
per capita sometimes I'm not entirely
sure I wish I'd taken pictures of the
spines didn't think until after ah yeah
that's one of those things where like I
gotta get rid of a bunch of stuff just
clean it out moving doing all this kind
of stuff and then
you know it's what it's just easy to not
do at the time and you remember it later
and you're like crap that's right I
should have done that
happens it happens
uh well we we went 20 minutes after I
said I might be here for 10 15. that's
all good though that's fun Layla Miley
Laila Malloy there we go meloy
yeah I think maybe Malloy I don't think
Malloy with the o on top or the little
I don't know what to call that
um
May I'm gonna go with Mei boy uh it's
not it's not only the Brits where where
ground floor equals first
well no that's that's the thing
is that no that that's that's the thing
uh is
what hotels don't have a 13th floor a
lot of a lot don't a lot don't
um garage sale versus boot sale that's
funny uh it's not only the Brits so okay
I'm from the US obviously so I'm
thinking there's a ground floor which is
the first floor and then there's a
second floor third floor floor
Etc right apparently Malloy is close
enough
or Maylo is close enough Malloy you're
the one I'm I try to pronounce things
right but
I I I I don't know the different like
the differentiations of the characters
of the A and the O and and what I should
do with each one you know what I mean uh
but
but that that's where I was confused the
other day is
people in England call the first floor
of the ground floor oh no no no first
floor of the ground floor and then the
second floor of the first floor third
floor the second floor so on so forth
and that didn't make sense to me until
sci-fi Quest about 20 seconds later said
oh May Lloyd ma okay I'll try again
later
uh
uh ground floor equals zero floor
see I I don't like that though I I do I
do but I don't we'll get into this whole
debate another day I do like it as an
actual like debate topic and it's silly
it's fun and one person's floor is
another person's ceiling
sci-fi you're you're joking around here
because you're the one who came up with
this debate in the first place you're
just
he's puppeteering you're he's puppeting
the strings around here that's okay and
and keeps it easy on me my brain doesn't
have to work as hard until it does so
basement is negative one that's where I
get confused that's that's where because
I want to say that's probably the
basement
like there's the ground floor which is
one
and then sub level one there so I
wouldn't I don't know is there a zero
but the the zero can't be the ground
floor no I didn't sarcastically
instigator my friend I love it I love it
I'm an instigator too it's how you get
things done sometimes
sg0
hmm
I don't know I don't know this is when I
just bang my head up against the wall or
just
sit on some books and and try to uh
what's that little have y'all seen that
funny little video of I think it's a boy
and like a class in China or something
he's just he has his hands on his book
and he's just
switches the page
looks at it and just
like he's just putting it in his head I
wish that was the case maybe maybe
with neuralink whenever it comes along
that becomes a little more feasible
we'll see
well would you have SG ground ID
Stargate grounded
that'd be funny Let the knowledge flow
in yes hmm
basement is a negative Ergo basement
yes we're gonna end there
and call it a day I appreciate y'all for
staying and being here this long y'all
are the best uh we will I guess call
these strictly M Cube streams from now
on but Sidetrack shall be here as well
Jamie and hopefully Matt should be here
most of the time as well and if Matt
wants to do double streams on his
channel because he wants to grow as well
and we're all just kind of
doing that we're in growth mode y'all I
like that it's fun
we'll we'll see exactly what next week's
gonna look like and we'll keep you
posted in the process come back check
tomorrow on M cubed of course Thursday
Friday for either a theater Thursday or
a film news Friday I don't think I'll be
able to get to both but one or the other
and we should be doing some star field
streams over on G cubed as well
pretty simple same thing as M cubed
spelled the same way all that just with
a G
switch switch that one letter well you
you got us we got you but
thank you all for being here thank y'all
thank y'all thank y'all a number system
that skips euro is primitive I we don't
skip who skipped zero when when did you
skip zero
the basement is zero
that
I'm going with basement
uh but we have sellers same thing that
one's semantics I love your rambling
topic it's great thank you I'm I'm a
rambler if you've never noticed uh this
was a great stream thank you all thank
you all for being here again uh I'm
gonna do a double outro I'm gonna play
the M cubed and Sidetrack intro slash
outro and then I'm gonna play just the M
cubed one
call it a day after that doubling up
double or nothing as they say cheers
Peter I hope you all have a great day
great great evening wherever you are all
the above
adios
[Music]